تعتبر الولايات المتحده النظام الصيني
استبداديا وتعتقد انه الوحيد القادر على
تحدي النظام الدولي القائم اما الصين فترى
ان الولايات المتحده تريد ان تبقي يا
هيمنتها على النظام العالمي المستمره منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
يتجلى الصراع او المنافسه الصينيه
الامريكيه اكثر في منطقه بحر جنوب الصين
وخليجي تايوان تقول الولايات المتحده ان
الهدف الاول للحفاظ على وجود عسكري كبير
في المنطقه هو حمايه حلفائها خصوصا تايوان
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان اما الهدف
الثاني فهو ضمانه حريه الملاحه التجاريه
والوصول الى اسواق المنطقه اما الصين
فتعتبروا محرجه بالصين منطقه نفوذ خالصه
لها وتعتبر تايوان جزءا من ترابها ولذلك
عملت على تطوير سلاحها البحري فانتقل عدد
قطع الى البحريه من 120 عام 2000 الى 360
عام 2020
كما اقامت جزر صناعيه وسلحتها ودخلت في
نزاعات مع عدد من دول المنطقه بشان
السياده على مناطق بحريه واسعه ومنعتها من
التنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه فيها الى جانب
هذا الصراع الاستراتيجيه الاقليمي هناك
منافسه اقتصاديه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده باعتبارهما القوتين الاولى
والثانيه ويمثلان معا اكثر من 35 في المئه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي تعاني
الولايات المتحده من عجز تجاري في علاقتها
مع الصين انتقل من 83 مليار دولار عام
2001 الى
375 مليار دولار عام 2017
ما تعتبره رغبه في مد الصين هيمنتها بعيدا
خصوصا في افريقيا من خلال مشروع طريق
الحرير تصين هي الشريك التجاري الاول
لافريقيا منذ 12 عاما وبلغت مبادلاته
تجاريه معها ما قيمته
187 مليار دولار عام 2019 وما بين 2000 و
2019 منحت الصين اكثر من 1000 قرض لحكومات
وشركات عامه افريقيه بقيمه
153 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]